now in the united states it paid to do
it because pension funds like california
calpers
state of new york
they said we're only going to do
business with firms that adopt these
progressive commitments well they said
you know what those are where the
biggest checks are coming from that's
the tune we're going to dance to and and
so so in a certain sense that when the
economic incentives were set up that way
it wasn't altogether surprising that
people responded to those incentives
all right you gave me a lot of avenues
to go down so let's back up for a second
because obviously i want to talk about
striving i want to talk about the new
book but woken i mean basically uh you
know you were laying out that that this
woke thing that we were all seeing it's
going through the universities it's on
television everywhere you turn on apple
tv that it's not just sort of this
organic thing coming from kids off
tumblr that there actually is an
organizational
ideology behind it so can you talk about
that a little bit because people always
ask me either when i do q and a's on the
show or i go out publicly where is it
coming from what is driving it truly
yes i mean look that took a whole whole
separate book length work to describe
but one of the things i said in that
book was that it was when wokeness met
capitalism that it actually became
unstoppable and it was supercharged with
the dollars that flow through our system
of free market american capitalism
that's when it really
became not just a challenge to the
system it became the system and it
happened in the aftermath of the 2008
financial crisis and i saw this
firsthand right i
got my first job at that hedge fund in
new york city in the fall of 2007 on the
eve of the 08 crisis
and the long story short and it is a
long story and it was you know it was my
last book so we could we could go on for
hours about this one but the short
version of it
is that
wall street realized they could go from
being the bad guys after the 08 crisis
to be in the good guys if they just said
the right things
muse about diversity and inclusion
immediate unjust impact of climate
change after you're flying a private jet
to davos
it's pretty good work if you can get it
it was a cynical arranged marriage
though between
two
partners in that marriage that did not
particularly love or respect one another
big business in the in the
neo-progressive woke movement but
together they were each able to get
something out of the trade it was more
like mutual prostitution
and that was what led to the birth of
woke inc it wasn't just woke and it
wasn't just the ink it was it was both
of them and that's what that that whole
tale was about i will tell you that over
the course of writing that book though i
was interested in both
the corporate cynicism behind it which
is what that book ended up being about
but i was also interested in the content
of the underlying ideology as well and
so the publisher kind of told me and
advisors who helped me put that book
together and said look you got to pick
one or the other start with the first
one and then and then actually the
unfinished work was what led to nation
of victims which is which is the book
that i'm putting out now so you know
that was that was a bit of the journey
of the two books the first one was
really about
the corporate financial fuel
and and and the second book is really
about the underlying flyer the kind of
the fire the conflict integration on
which
corporations threw that fuel and and
together i think i assume that the irony
should not be lost on anyone that as you
describe it it was capitalism that
allowed this thing to be unleashed which
is virulently anti-capitalist
of course and and you know what
ludwig von mises a famous economist uh
you know schumpeter joseph trumpeter
himself you know said various said very
similar things this is early 20th
century stuff from from from from von
mises that capitalism creates
a psychological need
filled by anti-capitalism
you know sharpener kind of predicted the
same thing the system of creative
destruction but first capitalism give
rock gives rise necessarily paves the
way to socialism that was kind of
schampener's thesis and it's it's
interesting you know we see their
predictions play out in the moment that
you and i live in i mean you're
technically a millennial you're a
millennial as well i'm i believe i'm 46
my friend i am so you're on the other
side
x yeah i am j you look good man so so i
don't know but i'm a millennial so i'm
i'm what 37 now so my generation i was
going to say our generation we'll call
my generation i have a lot of younger
friends
that's good you know whatever you get
it's a spectrum anyway your generation
sort of the younger part of your
generation counts in this is yeah you
know but the millennials in particular
we're on the receiving end i mean i'm
i'm personally not in the receiving end
of this but millennials as a generation
on the receiving end of the largest
intergenerational wealth transfer in
human history and there's something
about that that creates this
psychological need for self-criticism
and criticism of the very system that
created the wealth that you're otherwise
going to be on the receiving end of but
without actually making the sacrifice of
giving up that inheritance be able to
apologize for it with this new
self-found consciousness of your of your
privilege or whatever it is that lies at
the heart of the apologism that
characterizes and i don't even use the
word woke anymore because it's sort of
become a tired word but the modern
neo-progressive movement the apologist
culture that's that's really at the
heart of my next book which is the
victimhood culture that that permeates
our american fabric today are you
surprised that it rampaged through so
many businesses i mean businesses that
were were or should be based on actual
numbers it's one thing okay rampage is
through an entertainment company you
know somebody making movies
tv shows etc but like seemingly
everything accounting firms and banks
like the whole freaking thing that you
know these are people that actually have
to look at numbers and make sense based
on reality or at least they're supposed
to
yeah you know at first it's surprising
of course it's counterintuitive right
that's that's why it made for an
interesting book but
when you when you examine it it's
actually not surprising at all because
it serves the interests of many of the
people who are
the proper the biggest propagators of
this new ideology i mean look larry fink
at blackrock used this as a philosophy
to aggregate over 10 trillion dollars
the creating the world assets under
management
that's something that he couldn't have
done if it weren't for filling the void
created by the 2008 financial crisis and
telling people that this was actually
the new capitalism itself
and so you know i think the people on
top by the way without saying an iota
about those same words in china how do
you know it's in their self-interest you
talk about esg or dei or csr or whatever
your favorite three-letter acronym is
when they go over to the other
three-letter acronym from from esg dei
and csr to ccp to be able to do business
in china without saying a peep about esg
or dei because that's what it pays to do
over there now in the united states it
paid to do it because pension funds like
california calpers
state of new york
they said we're only going to do
business with firms that adopt these
progressive commitments well they said
you know what those are where the
biggest checks are coming from that's
the tune we're going to dance to and so
so in a certain sense that when the
economic incentives were set up that way
it wasn't all together surprising that
people responded to those incentives
i think you know in my new book is a
nation of victims we sort of talk about
that i talk about that at the individual
level as well
why is victimhood culture so rampant in
the united states it's a bit of a
curiosity right you know we have living
in the most prosperous moments in human
history and in american history why is
it then that we fashion ourselves to
think of ourselves as victims in every
given direction black victims white
white victims second generation asian
victims i mean it's everywhere
we've in certain senses create an
incentive structure in our country that
rewards someone for characterizing
themselves as a victim rather than as a
victor and so i think that you know it
doesn't it's not it's not a sort of a
cheesy humans respond to incentives kind
of argument all the way down but that is
an important part of the story and it's
certainly a part of the story that makes
it less surprising than you'd otherwise
think if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell